why hit the first shabby it's got a
little block by one chip Derek white
just steamrolled Rogich drew the foul
and finished and just a step late
creating the contact and somehow that
ball falls in to pop
[Music]
[Applause]
Spurs take this one away Gregg Popovich
dipped on the all-time woodland DeRosa
doubt it
rockets seven Oh run and looking for
more here with hardens it began and
there's back with his second steal white
Gordon
challenges in defensively rebound out to
doors of durin one big stuffs up for a
triple mama in the guts of the game and
making big shocker is Derrick 10 on the
shot clock
[Applause]
for three
go deep 1 10 100 Tunes working off that
high screen from LaMarcus and it's too
loud and brought to you by the tidy Bowl
man slow coming back into the action
[Music]
right now the Utah Jazz on this one
they're a man down and Derek white no
dribble and no trampling overs in the
Jazz with 26 points Tuesday night Derek
white is going back go for the alley-oop
and the bad hair day just get worse the
times over the jump shot and his triple
makes in 67 35 4 goes forwards how about
Derek white with the swipe from behind
this catches Carter's down to a tragic
money
[Music]
24 seconds he's filed
[Music]
[Applause]
Jared want to known it was good good
penetration through it up there is just
15 is that jig games against the Spurs
in the first two meetings la with the
Miss inside where is one the percentage
card and another steal off to Ford's at
the line
anticipation from them are playing out
of that TT white
[Applause]
the triple side mission this is the
basement back out
la gathers no Derek white didn't react
as well either ballclub
you'll get snapped awake here comes
DeRozan Derek white boy tire Arena on
his basketball card
oh just oh that should be an an one
that's filthy Derek
Wow what a performance in the third
quarter
that's as nasty as it gets inside and
white with a steal oh boy is six of them
last night it's got a great defensive
instincts Oh a million fans oh the folks
coming in tonight
[Applause]
and among the leaders attached thanks
Bruce 17 absolutely
[Applause]
because he's been better than advertised
look at that explosiveness that you got
your point guard right now maybe not a
tougher shot in this game throws under
white on the drive over Drummond
goodness crisis that's this kid just
goes out of play
Derek white playing lights-out Spurs on
a 22 to run deep in position Adams
County just eaten convert white films
right there from that high post area
[Applause]
Pence's been down by four shooter makes
a move down the price
watch this block here and the got the
elbow as grant was coming down which
opened up the skin and the blood came
out the printer wanted to dance on a
little bit you're right that should have
been a turnover back in his hands
[Applause]
Rosanne absolutely wide open underneath
[Applause]
white gets the step lays it in plus the
fact he's not sped up he's got a big on
him so Anthony Tolliver does the rip
through movement now look at where his
eyes were the whole time on a plane to
fly up here to New Orleans and it's
played very well in his limited minutes
Derek white an and-one as he drives all
the way to the rack
free throw on the team the Spurs run
floor again
here comes Derrick white after the steel
- ow
empty Italian restaurants damn egg yolk
ravioli
we cut the ravioli in the hot deal
undock y'all that's that's when you know
you're in a really fancy place it's all
food we shot all the time Marco capsid
offensive rebounding for the category
said Davis he's always been a good job
that start to pick up some of the money
[Music]
he's taken on the challenge just took
the right angle off that time screen how
Lowery's laundry bag by mistake and then
in trying on the socks his wife gets the
slime he said hey these sucks a little
bit long and they tip it to Griffin
ahead your Wellington
[Applause]
take your pick
I gots mother two or three times points
overall Gemara kicks it off the white to
white on the opposite side of the floor
beautiful crossover have to get that one
off smart play once again aggressively
blowing out of the barn Barton - yo
kitchen deflected and DeMar DeRozan and
get it easy to yo get you double figures
with 10 for the visitors
Darren white picks it back on - oh I am
elastic Paris you see how many there's
leaning forward to get that shot up just
to confuse Derek sighs white in the
paint was vicious and this is over a guy
who's 7 1 so that should be worth 4
points it does about adding a four point
line that should be a full pointer
you're throwing it down over a guy who's
seven one white again great defensive to
win that time Derek's the other way
go ahead there Derek line getting
physical in the open chord then gets his
chance to show off mark to eat isn't a
dance it did an excellent anticipation
take 14 points 6 rebounds she is their
leading scorer tonight
white ball ahead Latasha to the rock up
beautiful Zack I'll treat you with that
film bring the pin fan out a beautiful
live out there start to dance on the big
guy
[Music]
white from DS continues to improve
missed the previous shot steps in rhythm
contestant too late into home court
advantage to so yeah they're only two
games in the lost column out of fourth
there's white getting the bucket in the
paint and drawing the foul rays if he's
truly an all-time fridge Derek white has
to hoist it with two on the shot clock
and it goes in it didn't hit the shot
clock just hit the top of the backboard
so it counts white laughs for all
furs are they are Samara DeRosa just
fires it to Derek white along the
baseline but he once he gets rocket on
his back doesn't allow back in the play
and then just outmuscles him near the
rim until they start with double teaming
me we're taking the ball out of my hands
Loffler swatted away by white and he
comes up with a loose one Derek in
traffic looking for all bridge finds
with Kimball Walker and it's almost
identical you have the UH Kopernik over
at the left Derek white stays in it
comes up at the block up Sprint's to
Charlotte Hornets players rip the ball
no less love des Thompson
there's Derek white I have your first
tragic moment they call it trying to do
too much
Myrtle lays it off for LA and he knows
how to take care of mrs. Finch
outscore the Spurs been the staple for
San Antonio what's up
to young on the bench right now
hopefully this honks unit that's out on
the floors goes total scoring the ball
[Applause]
[Music]
looks to LA Nance pokes it away go foul
call night in the paint
ed blocked by Derek wife oh that's a
great play by sorry Brandon 90 towles
his body
[Applause]
from there from there the Mavericks
again within eight six on the shot clock
for Derek white night tonight and
playoff rows and double team they take
it out of his hands
good ball fake by Jeff white you know
Derek white doesn't look the product and
the Spurs with the board we've gone up
and down without you good team Oh with
some dynamite three is what a move white
tone Paul Millsap
all these things the double-team Derek
white [ __ ] low drives
wide open as it goes that's how you play
over the dope team right there you kind
of use the defensive momentum against
them back to the basket yeah missing the
layup is one thing but and continue to
attack this Derek white got the message
right on cue you know at the top of the
key area and they left Bryn Forbes
another great block of Yaakov early Jam
on yo kids to the terabyte one another
stop he's having all kinds of victims
38% and 37 in the regular season
Derek white on the drive
[Music]
new bomber there are quiet beautiful
spin move slips and a story with that
left hand luggage double deep comes to
burn
[Applause]
I three in a wild one in Game three
challenge coming up with that charm that
chews it up again
by
[Applause]
here is DeRozan we have 19 of the third
quarter
[Applause]
brought them back to the ward I haven't
gotten very many books tonight
the dragons are chosen
let's just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for this awareness not like rolling it
up is foolish here at home thirty twos
and I hope these teams in hand
[Music]
[Applause]
sit back beautifully furniture he now
has 17 what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content